hallo jetzt wieder mal vorne und kennt
ihr das wenn ihr begrüßung total
verpackt oder irgendwelche begrüßung
total kaka aussehen
wir haben uns mal heute was dazu
ausgedacht und wünschen euch viel spaß
meine lieblings nächte dürfte
muss dann auch
so lag in die hand so unhöflich und bei
dir auch super du mit jacqueline das gut
über die runden
ich habe die pille abgesetzt und dann
wollte plötzlich mehr auch irgendwie
danke
wir versuchen jetzt größeren richtigen
zutaten oder war ja leute das war's für
diese woche wie immer wenn es euch
gefallen hat einen daumen nach oben
geben tut nicht weh und kostet nix
unbedingt bei tommy blackout
vorbeischauen der hübsche man der oder
bei mir war ich vermute euch hier ein
video das ist auch musiker und nichts
wochenende kommt von ihm ein lied raus
ozean und ein geiles video dazu also
macht euch auf was geiles gefasst
ansonsten wünsche ich euch nur noch eine
schöne woche und deren sie das nächste
mal geld